it's over they're all gone bank it's
time it's time you say what happened
[Music]
Frank want you to meet my cousin Russell
Bufalino there watch this is where the
tough guys around here did he tell you
I'm not afraid
tough place I mean I think so I was one
of a thousand working stiffs I thought I
wasn't no more you got a good friend
here you don't know how good a friend
you got Russell he took a shine to me
right away after a while he started
giving me little things to do
[Music]
I know you read a lot of things about me
I just want to say I'm sorry
I know I wasn't a good dad I know that I
know that I was just trying to protect
all this from what you didn't see what I
see
what I've been through a friend of ours
is having a little trouble friend at the
top now your friend this is Jimmy Hoffa
there's a meet you you want to be a part
of this fight a part of this history
whatever you need me to do I'm available
only three people in the world have one
of these and only one of them is Irish
now strong I made you I know things they
don't know why no he said that you sure
he said that I'm worried
nobody threatens offer I got records I
got tapes they're done
I had to put you into steps or later
everybody put her as a date when he's
gonna go
I know how you feel frightened
trust me I know we'll bring you back
after get your car
yeah
you
you